honestly we're talking here in
luxembourg but of course the fdth asia
pacific has a massive event coming up in
may tell us how the planning is going
for that great thank you brian yes so we
have our uh event taking place
between 17 and 8 and may
in bangkok
we expect it to be a pretty large event
as usual and
we have a full support from the local
operators they're going to come and
participate we're having participations
for you some new countries
that are getting into ftth so we're
expecting cambodia representatives from
cambodia myanmar laos and others we've
invited them so we expect vips from them
coming in we also have a very good nice
panel set up of good 40 to 50 speakers
from the industry uh including uh very
recently confirmed from google so we
expect somebody very senior from google
coming in and joining us so it should be
a very exciting event for us that's
amazing that's amazing now i'm hearing
all the time that asia's leading the
world in ftth deployment you know what's
your what's your perception of the
market at the moment well as you know
last year we we hit the
100 million mark and it came off on a
celebration of the ten year of formation
of the fcth council asia pacific and
then we're very excited that we are uh
you know 100 million uh and then ticking
still it's still coming very strong
we're from the council side you know
we're working on a lot of the new
applications and solutions that we're
seeing evolving in the market uh such as
the ng pawn two uh we're also looking at
you know deployments such as in open
access networks um so these are some of
the interesting things that are
happening in asia pacific at this moment
tell us how the work of the council
helps the industry move forward what
kind of things do you get involved with
right so so um recently you know we we
have uh formed a couple of new
committees one of them being the smart
cities committee another one that we're
working on is fiverr as a service uh
committee uh these are uh there to
provide white papers we
talk about the best practices best
standards and that provides some sort of
guidance to uh you know the industry as
to how the ftth is evolving and what are
the other services that are coming in
and that's how the council contributes
uh to to the industry so you're
confident that you're going to help keep
asia right at the cutting edge well um
you know the way we look at it we are
way ahead in numbers and
we'll keep on adding more numbers to it
year by year and then so it's it's 100
million and beyond fantastic thanks very
much for talking to us and best of luck
for the event in may thank you very much
brian